it's birthday season in my house
and it's just occurred to me that my
youngest girl has never had a cake
and considering she would have watched me
baking cakes for everybody else
for the last few years
and yet never had one for herself
that just feels like an absolute tragedy
and to be totally honest I'm feeling like
the worst mum in the world right now
but she's my youngest and also sort of
kind of an accident
and I don't harbour any resentment
but you know what it's like when you get
through all of the other kids
and you just kinda run out of energy
and she's always so good about it
she doesn't even complain
so I just didn't think that she minded
not to mention she's got some interesting
dietary requirements to work around
which makes cake baking a whole lot more challenging
but today
we're gonna right some wrongs and
put all of her favourite foods
in one place
I started by boiling a potato and a kumera
before getting started on my cake batter
I piped on the frosting
and topped it with some crispy chicken fat and some peanut butter
and then it was time to sing Happy Birthday
to the birthday girl
this is Goldie she's our very excitable Hungarian vizsla
and today she turns 3
and while I was cutting the cake
she took off her hat and just opted for
the classic birthday suit look
and the good thing about this cake
Goldie is honestly
you don't need to share it
personally I didn't think that I had
baking a dog cake on my bingo card
but it made for one happy girl